on termine avec les états unis où
l'année 2021 et est marqué par une
hausse importante des homicides après
avoir réduit les budgets alloués la
police dans le sillage du mouvement
black light ce matin la tendance est
désormais à linverse les explications
avec notre correspondant à washington
tom abonnés
la vague de protestation suivant la mort
de georges floyd a lancé un débat
faut-il démantelé la police c'est
l'appel lancé régulièrement par des
manifestants désireux que le budget des
villes soient mieux réparties en
piochant dans le budget des départements
de police en mai 2021 encore ce slogan
résonnait devant le siège de la police
de los angeles
il continue d'essayer de bâtir de forces
de polices militariste et au lieu de
gérer les problèmes de notre communauté
pour réduire le crime il essaie de
répondre aux crimes et en même temps ils
ne font rien concernant les problèmes
que nous avons comme le manque de
logements
je ne suis pas à 100% pour le
démantèlement de la police je pense que
la police doit être ré entraîner que cet
argent devrait être investi pour cela je
pense que l'argent devrait aussi être
investis dans des programmes sociaux
avec les communautés commencé quand les
enfants sont encore jeunes ces appels
avaient été entendus dès 2020 par
certaines mairies pour la plupart
démocrate des dizaines de villes ont
ainsi réduit le budget municipal alloués
à la police à new york par exemple ce
budget a été restreint 800 millions de
couples sur un budget initialement
estimé à 6 milliards de dollars sauf
qu'entre temps la criminalité a connu
une hausse presque sans précédent aux
états unis en 2021 deux tiers des villes
les plus peuplées du pays ont connu une
augmentation du nombre d'homicides pour
certains il ne fait aucun doute qu'il ya
un lien direct entre ces réductions
budgétaires et la recrudescence des
crimes de nombreuses villes ont
finalement fait machine arrière on ne
compte plus les exemples de maires qui
décident de rétablir les budgets
précédemment alloués à la police voire
même dans certains cas de les augmenter
à new york portland ou encore los
angeles pour ne citer qu'elles il a été
convenu d'euros nero budget précédent
encore tout récemment la maire de la
ville californienne d'oakland prenait la
même décision et reconnaissez une erreur
nous devons fortement augmenté la
prévention mais cela ne devrait pas être
au détriment de la police et c'était je
crois l'erreur qui a été faite l'été
dernier par le conseil municipal qui a
décidé de coupes budgétaires sur le
département de police ce n'était pas
nécessaire à chicago après avoir proposé
une forte baisse du budget de la police
la mère en appel à l'aide fédérale pour
tenter d'endiguer la violence dans sa
ville on en arrive donc presque à une
unanimité plutôt que de réduire la
présence policière il faudrait garantir
un budget conséquent pour assurer la
tranquillité des ruses américaine le
problème c'est qu'il est devenu de plus
en plus difficile d'embaucher des
policiers et qu'ils sont aussi de plus
en plus nombreux à quitter leurs
fonctions dénonçant un climat qui se
détériore et un manque de soutien
politique de fait le lien s'est distendu
entre une partie de la population
américaine et sa police des affaires
très médiatisées de bavures policières
et un sentiment d'impunité dans les
rangs des forces de l'ordre ils y ont
sans doute contribué
après l annonce du verdict contre derek
chauvine jugé coupable du meurtre de
john floyd jo bayonne avait lui-même
reconnu la nécessité de réformer la
police manche
la plupart des hommes et des femmes qui
portent le badge servent leurs
communautés de façon honorable mais les
quelques-uns qui ne respectent pas les
règles doivent être tenus pour
responsables
il y en avait aujourd'hui un a été tenu
pour responsable personne ne doit être
au dessus des lois le verdict
d'aujourd'hui envoie ce message
mais ce n'est pas assez on ne peut pas
s'arrêter là dans le but de permettre un
changement réel et des réformes nous
pouvons y nous devons faire plus pour
réduire la probabilité que des tragédies
comme cela ne se reproduise
mais pour le moment les réformes sont
bloquées faute de consensus politique
si l'actualité américaine met
régulièrement en lumière la nécessité de
lutter contre les violences policières
la réduction des budgets ne semble pas
être la piste à suivre pour joe biden
écartelé entre les exigences de sa base
et l'urgence de mettre un terme à la
flambée de la criminalité le dossier
s'annonce comme particulièrement
sensible